[Music]
as of this recording almost a million of
you watched my chat with jordan peterson
and ben shapiro last week on youtube and
a couple hundred thousand more of you
have listened to the audio podcast while
the mainstream media continues to
spoon-feed the masses soundbite
clickbait we're here doing some real
proof of concept work to prove that you
guys are a lot smarter than they think
while mainstream media focuses on trumps
diet coke habit we're here talking about
the Marxist roots of post-modernism and
the secular and religious arguments over
where rights come from i received a
bunch of emails from you guys after the
livestream saying that jordan often says
things that go over your head but you
actually go ahead and pause the video
and do some research for yourself I'll
be totally honest with you sometimes he
says things that fly by me as well and
while I usually try to pause him to
clarify obviously I can't always do that
in the midst of a conversation while
you're learning through these
conversations know that I'm learning
right next to you
after the Petersons Shapiro live stream
Jordan got in a well-deserved nap and
then spoke to a sold-out crowd of 2,000
people at the Orpheum Theatre here in LA
Jordan was nice enough to let me
introduce him as a special surprise
guest to the audience and I got to tell
you it was truly the best reception I've
ever received on stage I did a couple
minutes to stand up cracking jokes about
lobsters and the importance of cleaning
your room but there was something beyond
just the laughs that I could feel on the
stage the room felt lit with intellect
and curiosity 2,000 strangers coming
together to hear a middle-aged
psychology professor talk about how
fixing yourself is the only way to fix
the world
this simply wouldn't have happened even
two years ago because so many of you who
dare think differently were silenced by
false cries of racism and bigotry people
like Jordan and Ben are using their
intellect to say what they believe and
that in turn is showing millions of
people out there that they can do the
exact same thing whether you like or
hate Trump this idea revolution is
directly related to his election
everything is up in the air right now
from our political institutions to our
educational institutions to our media
instead
toons as Eric Weinstein and I discussed
a few months back perhaps some of us
would have preferred less upheaval to
get us to address the problems with
these institutions but perhaps that more
selective tactful upheaval actually
never happens as I said to Eric he
wanted a panther in a china shop but all
that was available was the bull as the
Rolling Stones taught us you can't
always get what you want but you get
what you need as most of you probably
have already seen we followed up our
chat with Peterson and Shapiro with the
brothers weinstein Eric and Brett it was
their first public appearance together
ever and I have to say that my brain is
still in recovery mode from taking in so
many high-level important ideas if the
dial of ideas was turned too low for the
last few years it's quickly moving into
the hot position the dial is moving
because the conversations were having
here are finally starting to leak out
into the rest of the world
that's why thousands of you are showing
up at Jordan Peterson events and at live
Sam Harris podcasts and by the way Sam
and Jordan disagree on pretty much
everything especially the most
fundamental existential questions that
exist yet we're all on the same side
because the only real enemy is the
authoritarians who want to control us so
that they can have a silenced once you
realize that you'll suddenly find
yourself with many more allies and many
less enemies so it probably goes without
saying that I'm feeling incredibly
positive about the direction things are
heading and I hope that you are too this
month we're gonna continue having real
conversations with people who are truly
affecting the world with their thoughts
and their actions we've got a five-time
bank robber who became a Georgetown Law
professor we've got a former head of
FEMA and we've got a nuclear power
expert running for governor of
California also I'm thrilled to share
with you that we're doing five shows in
five days with five experts on five
different presidents of the United
States to celebrate presidents week from
some founders like Jefferson Adams and
Madison to JFK and Lincoln the stories
of our past are as relevant as ever as
we fight for the liberty of today oh and
yes we'll be doing plenty more of the
three-person sit downs as well who do
you want sitting down across from each
other let us know in the comments right
down below after all there's an idea
revolution happening right now and it
may not be televised
but it's definitely
to be streamed we're continuing our
partnership with learn liberty this week
and joining me today is an associate
professor of law at Georgetown Law
School as well as the founder of prison
professors dot-com
Sean Hopwood welcome to the Rubin report
all right thanks for having me so I got
to tell you man I have been in
partnership with learn Liberty for about
a year and a half or so and it's a great
partnership they send me a list of great
professors and academics from all over
the country they say if you want to talk
to any of these people
we'll make them available easy enough
you have by far the craziest bio of
anyone that they have passed along to me
I suspect you know that in advance you
don't have many public intellectuals who
have gone to federal prison for robbing
banks you are the first one out of the
law I mean they've given us lists of
hundreds of people that we select out of
I I've gotten used to be on the Freak
Show
yeah at one point it used to bother me
but I I tend to embrace it now yeah so
yes you spent 12 years in a federal
prison for bank robbery we're obviously
gonna have to hear that story should I
be concerned at all that this is in my
house you've now seen my security system
and everything else I think you'll be
okay yeah when I took a meeting while
you were sitting in the green room I
thought maybe he could be you know doing
some stuff but yeah yeah probably
emailing with students yeah all right
that's my new life these days
that's your new life you have cleaned up
you're wearing a suit you've got legit
as they say I've cleaned up I brought my
First Amendment socks with me yeah yeah
Oh
given the finger to the man that's right
all right I'm a big believer on the
First Amendment I'm pretty much a First
Amendment absolutist me too all right
well then we're in good company here all
right so here we go so let's just start
with it with the big story you've robbed
a bank what are you doing
yeah robbed five of them what was I
doing I was a young 20 year old man who
had no purpose in life and did not way
out the consequences of my actions on
myself so it's not hard to realize that
I wasn't really thinking about the
consequences of my actions on anyone
else and everyone always wants to what
was the big reason why and the reason is
I was young
20 and stupid and part of my Redemption
out of that was just growing up all
right so just tell me how this even
happens when does the idea of I'll rob a
bank like you can be young and yes and
misguided and everything else and Daffy
you might you know steal some stuff from
the candy store
it's a robbing a bank differently yeah
no that's right a friend of mine invited
me to the bar in my hometown sprawling
metropolis of 2,500 people and rural
Nebraska and said hey what do you think
about robbing a bank and most people
would have said no you're crazy laughs
done anything and my response was that
sounds like a great idea
and so we discussed it over beers and I
don't think either one of us thought we
were gonna actually do it yeah that
night but we started taking steps and
then once we got into it it was kind of
took me on a downward spiral yeah so
from that conversation to to the first
robbery how long was that probably six
months okay so now just had that we had
to hype ourselves up to actually do it
yeah
so what were those conversations like I
mean what were their multiple plans of
how to go about doing this was this all
like the way you see it in old western
just showing up at the know yeah give me
some yeah we planned it out we had
stolen a car went to the bank ran in the
bank with guns yelled at everyone
grabbed as much money as we could we
never intended to hurt anyone
the guns were there pretty much for show
and then we left and dumped the stolen
car and got into a grain truck because
this was August in Nebraska and no one's
gonna think about bank robbers being in
a grain truck and we drove lives and you
did this five times yeah you know once
we started doing it I had to use drugs
and alcohol to kind of get over the fact
that I had a lot of guilt it's not like
I didn't know this was wrong yeah and so
once we got into it we started spending
money when you make using money it's
easy to spend it yeah just was a year
of trying to party that's fascinating so
you get all this money and now the guilt
of the action is now the financial part
that's fueling yeah sure your need to do
it again yeah and I was going through
depression and some other issues and I
just I needed I needed somebody to say
what are you doing and I never really
got that and the guys I were with we're
all in the same place early 20s didn't
have a job didn't know what they wanted
to do with their life and we kind of
filled each other for this year-long
spree yeah
putting aside the the drugs for a second
I mean what about the rush of just doing
it I would imagine you know even though
it it's a criminal act obviously but
just like getting away with something
that sounds so crazy ya know it's not
really a rush every time you go in the
bank everything in your body is the only
you do not do this you kind of have to
shut that off yeah you kind of have to
shut rational thought down because if it
was rational you would not be doing it
if you were thinking rationally you
would not walk into a bank because you
know at the end of the day I got less
than $200,000 for all those banks well
served 11 years in prison and ended up
having to pay all the money back anyway
and so rationally didn't make much sense
from a cost-benefit analysis maybe isn't
the best idea well this is this is why
this is one of the big reasons why we
impose long sentences on people in this
country is this belief in general
deterrence if I give you a 20-year
sentence it's going to deter everyone
else all the literature says that that
doesn't actually happen
yeah people that commit crimes are a lot
of it is young men 18 to 25 these are
not people that weigh out the
consequences mm-hmm drug addiction
alcoholism mental health issues again
not people that weigh out the
consequences of their actions but even
if they did let's just pretend they did
mm-hmm what would they have to do to
find out how long they would be
sentenced for a particular they would
have to find one of five thousand
federal statutes right that sets the
mandatory minimum and maximum penalties
then they'd have to read a 500-page
guideline manual that judges and lawyers
miss apply every day to thank
anyone's actually doing that is
ludicrous yeah I never met one person 11
years in prison who knew how much time
they were facing but this is the primary
argument that people like the Attorney
General and other the tough-on-crime
crowd believes we should pose long
sentences because it will deter everyone
else yeah so this is what you've really
devoted your life to since and I want to
get to all that obviously and we just
briefly spoke about the Attorney General
I want to talk about him because I'm
frustrated about some stuff as well okay
so how much time cook place for those
five bank robberies like what kind of
time frame are we looking at less than a
year less than a year so within a year
okay now you get caught you end up in a
federal prison for I thought it was 12
you said 11 but maybe there's three
months we'll have a sentence but I got
good time for behaving in prison okay so
I served less than 11 years okay so less
than the 11 years just tell me what that
process even just tell me first what
that first day of showing up at a
federal prison is like it's not what you
would think it's not orange is the new
black it's not orange is the new black
the first day in prison and the first
week in prison felt like freedom and the
reason I say that is I was moved around
like many people that are pretrial from
County Jail to County Jail where you're
locked down maybe 20 hours out of the
day and when I got to prison I could
actually go outside I hadn't been
outside in oh oh nine months well when I
got to prison I could go outside I could
go to the library I could pick out books
I could do something to occupy my mind
and so the first couple weeks in prison
outside of the part of being scared to
death felt like more freedom yeah what
was the scary part beyond just being in
car being like just all the physical
threats here like physical threats
threats of sexual assault you know I
watched a lot of people with medical
issues die in federal prison because
they weren't adequately treated and you
know then the real punishment is you
don't you're cut off from all your
family and community ties which is a
problem because we know that people that
are able to maintain community and
family ties is key for people coming out
of prison especially if you come out of
prison you get a
and you lose the job or get fired if you
don't have family or some sort of
community to fall back on that's usually
when people go back to committing crime
right and that's part of the reason of
high rates of recidivism yeah in all of
this stuff
yeah the rates of recidivism in this
country are not good they range from 45
percent to 75 percent we have some state
prison systems that within five years
everyone leaving the prison seventy five
percent of them will come back I mean
that's just mind-blowing
like putting everything else aside that
we're going to talk about for the next
hour if just the idea that you put
people here to punish them for this
crime and then more than half in many
cases and you're saying sometimes
significantly more end up back there
man I mean what it what a failure what a
true failure what what I mean government
programs that fail three out of four
times and no one really it is disturbing
yeah you know anyone who has an out date
and is going to come out of prison we
should be trying to rehabilitate those
people for a number of reasons one
public safety do not want people coming
out of prison and committing new crimes
new victims it costs a lot of money to
reprosecution der and then their
incarceration so you got that issue but
you also have an issue with we want
people to come back and lead law buying
successful lives and if you've just
warehouse somebody for 10 years and then
you kick them out to the streets with no
or little support and no family or
community ties and then you expect a
miracle to happen and then when it
doesn't we say oh you were evil because
we you were gonna fail and go back to
prison commit a new crime anyway yeah
now you were truly the aberration in the
system because you have a little bit of
a Shawshank kind of story here because
Andy Dufresne took things into his own
hands one in a couple different ways
legally and by digging the the tunnel
but you started getting into law this is
fascinating to me yeah I got a job at
the president law library and for the
first couple months all I did was hand
out the books they were big they were
thick they were intimidating when I did
whole one down off the shelves and read
it felt like it was written in another
language right who was reading the books
I mean was everyone there trying to
solve their case with now there were
people there was there were a lot but
there were people trying to fight their
case especially in federal prison when
when a lot of people were getting twenty
thirty year mandatory minimums for a
handful of crack cocaine mm-hmm so
people are trying to fight their cases
and I didn't want anything to do with
that until June 26 of 2000 the Supreme
Court handed down a decision called
aprende V New Jersey I like everyone
else in federal prison thought that this
might apply to the federal sentencing
guidelines so I started learning the law
on my own and was never able to get any
relief for myself but what I found was I
enjoyed solving this legal puzzle and
kind of writing out the solution so I
started helping other people in prison
keep going then what happened this is
where it gets good that there's always
up to here to your career now and your
whole life yeah I started writing memos
for people friends of mine their lawyers
saying hey check out these issues and
here's some case law the lawyers often
time would be like yeah whatever I mean
do people think you were now yeah I did
what about their prisoners think like
well I mean they don't know good legal
work from bad right so many of them had
bad lawyers to begin with and they were
desperate so they would help me and I
finally started to write a briefer to
and we would file post-conviction
motions and the third legal brief I ever
prepared was for a friend of mine named
John fellers who was filing what's
called a petition for writ of certiorari
to the United States Supreme Court I
didn't know a great deal about the
Supreme Court but I knew it was
different than filing in other courts
that court gets 8,000 petitions 7,000
petitions a year they grant 70 to 80
cases got a 1% chance that the 1% is for
lawyers filing breaks to a court when
you are filing pro se as an indigent
prisoner with no lawyer and you're the
prisoners name is on the front cover
yeah a chance of getting one of those
heard is about 1% of one
Wow and so do you know how many times
that was done before you
I think it's been done 20 times Wow
25 times since the 1950s not a lot yeah
so you know I didn't think a great deal
about John's case I thought we were
right on the issues and I thought the
issues were important
John transferred to another prison and I
I forgot about his case until one
morning at 6:30 in the morning a friend
of mine came running and screaming out
of the housing unit Sean Sean you know
let's be in federal prison I thought
what did I say to him yesterday it wants
to come fight me at 6:30 in the morning
yeah usually when people are running and
screaming at each other not present it's
not aggressive but you don't normally go
to a fight carrying a newspaper in your
hand and what he had was a copy of the
USA USA Today saying that the court had
granted John fellers case how unlikely
that was given John had filed without a
lawyer and it actually quoted from the
brief that I had pecked out on a prison
typewriter I knew that was a big deal
did I know that it would lead to doing
this work long term no that I know it
was I was gonna go to law school or
become a lawyer no and I certainly never
thought I would end up as a law
professor at Georgetown yeah so what
happened right after that I mean did the
prison administrators go man this guy's
yeah well the big break for John fellers
and and myself was that an attorney took
the case over and not just any attorney
has named Seth Waxman he's the former
Solicitor General of the United States
and one of the top appellate lawyers in
the country he took the case and I think
most people and with his background
Harvard undergrad Yale Law School
clerked for federal judges worked at the
Department of Justice was the Solicitor
General would have said hey good job
math mr. Dale House lawyer without a
bachelor's degree
great work we'll take it from here and
yet he did the exact opposite they would
send in he and his firm Wilmer Hale
would send in drafts of the brief I
would markup it with notes and I would
send it back out one point I know one
point I had a conference call in my
counselor's office was sattim three
other lawyers
the week before oral arguments and SAP
asked me Sean can you think of any
questions that the justices might ask
that we haven't thought about and I'm
sitting there thinking I'm like I have
been self-learning the law for 18 months
I've never even taken freshman English
ya know I have no idea what the courts
gonna ask you and they started laughing
but it was quite the experience what do
you make of I mean it's a fascinating
that Waxman was willing to do this do
you think it was truly he was trying to
get your insight as a prisoner I mean
obviously he saw a good legal mind even
if it was a novice at the time do you
think there was also like just like a PR
element to that as well like I'm gonna
stick with this guy and there's some
value there too I think he was curious I
think he was curious that he had looked
at this petition that was typed on a
prison typewriter and had been granted
and he thought it was a really good work
product and he was surprised when he
discovered that it had been prepared by
a federal prisoner with no background in
the law whatsoever who had just kind of
been picking this up on his own yeah and
and I think he thought that there was
value there and and you know he became a
mentor to me we won the case nine to
zero and he has been a good friend he
introduced me a couple months ago at the
DC bar galas I want young lawyer of the
Year award
Seth walked up there and introduced me
to the crowd and we were just sitting
there at the table thinking things have
come full circle for us yeah it's so
funny because you're a young guy the
idea of like typing this thing up on a
typewriter you just that alone did a
whiteout and cut right out yeah you
think you could trade that because I
feel like there's some value to this
probably things you can do it right out
oh yeah yeah yeah I typed up a lot of
things on a present typewriter almost
all the briefs I prepare I never was
allowed to touch a computer while I was
incarcerated so when I get out in 2008
I had never been on the Internet
incredibly never seen an iPhone and iPad
and iPod one of the things that I
struggled was finding the jobs 2008 it
was the height of the recession no one
was finding work let alone
the bank robber that just did 11 years
in federal prison yeah tell me about
that day when you when they officially
say to you okay you're getting out a
little early and then what is it like
when you're actually putting out is it
are you literally putting on the clothes
that you walked in with it they say no
that's sort of the image that yeah right
somebody had sent me clothes my brother
picked me up to take me to the halfway
house I still had six months of custody
with the Bo P but I was going to serve
it at the halfway house across the river
from Nebraska and Council Bluffs Iowa
and my brother picks me up and we drive
and we go to a Walmart and I needed to
pick up toothpaste and I remember just
being stuck in the Walmart in an aisle
because there was a wall of toothpaste
and I had not had choice mm-hmm for over
a decade and it was overwhelming and I'm
not one that stresses or gets a great
deal of anxiety but I tell you my first
30 days at the halfway house I was
consuming four to five thousand calories
a day and losing weight well just
because of the anxiety of trying to
figure out this new world yeah you know
one of the places that my big break was
getting a job with khakha legal briefs
this company in Omaha that helps lawyers
all over the country file briefs to the
US Supreme Court they had asked me I
told them I had this reference letter
from Seth Waxman that really impressed
him I didn't tell them the rest of the
story yeah yeah don't ask where I was
really they said send us a PDF I didn't
know what a PDF was no one else in the
halfway house did either so when I walk
into the interview I have to pull this
reference letter out of my pocket and
hand it to them yeah and you know if
that if that cost me that job I'm not
sitting here today so tell me about that
so now you so now you're oh you know
what let's just do a little more on
prison itself and then we'll move into
everything that you're working on now I
think when we think of prison you know
so much of it it's just what we see in
TV and movies you know I watched eyes
years ago I watch our knees the new
black now like we think of like just so
much crime actually in prison which
sounds like it should be the reverse of
the way it is but yet there is how much
of that did you see in the federal
system
I saw more federal drug
more I saw more drugs in federal prison
than I ever saw outside as someone that
was doing drugs before une yeah and
there were several guards that were
federally indicted during my time in
prison it's kind of ironic to me that
you have a prison with two fences with
razor wire around it and really high
security and we can't keep the drugs out
of federal prison how are we ever gonna
do that for an entire country yeah
that's why the war on drugs will never
be successful was there a real
difference in the type of prisoner that
was there for you know obviously there's
some well is a bank robber he's not
considered a white that's not a
white-collar crime right now it's a
violent crime right of course so but
what is there a difference between okay
so you have someone that's you know
murderers and rapists and you know then
there's the sort of a lesser violent
crime something like a bank robber
versus just the people that did drugs
either either sold but I'm really
talking with the people who just did
drugs was there a real sort of
separation between those two types of
people know what I saw in prison was
there was a small sliver of people who
were dangerous and who would be very
difficult to reform without a lot of
behavioral changes yeah but it's a very
small sliver most of the people I saw
especially people for drug crimes most
of them were doing drugs and selling
drugs to support their habit and they
just needed a year or two of being clean
mm-hmm Oh problem was they would get
clean after two years and realized oh
I've got 18 more years to do in federal
prison I also just saw a lot of guys
that you know we're just regular guys
that that made bad choices and had
amazing talents and had the capacity to
get out and lead law-abiding successful
lives but they needed a little support
and they needed some incentives to take
rehabilitation programming and there
wasn't a lot of programming at the
prison yeah all right now let's let's
shift that so you so you leave prison
you get your first legit gig so what
actually was your job your first job
yeah so I consulted with lawyers every
day on the phone about filing their
briefs in the US Supreme Court
and you know that first year was
difficult for the people that worked at
cockle it was difficult for my wife I
went from an environment with nothing
but guys that were in federal prison for
11 years to an office of almost all
women and and was with my wife and I
talked like a prisoner acted like a
prisoner and they had to really sand off
some rough edges that first year yeah
with alle I mean it just a lot of [ __ ]
no I mean I mean so I would get
frustrated when a lawyer would call me
up and say hey I've got this petition
due in two days and I would said well
good send it here will help get you
filed well I haven't written it yet and
you know they're representing someone
who's got a 30-year mandatory minimum
that would make me mad and and one time
I got called into the office manager and
she said Sean you know our whole job
here is customer service so you can't
really tell lawyers to get their [ __ ]
yeah just little things like that that
you know I I had been in a different
environment and it took me a while to
adapt yeah well I think clearly that
adaptation is what has led to some of
your success how much did you see sort
of lawyers that were just part of the
machine that kind of weren't doing
anything wasting a lot of times they
could build people where for you it was
like I found this information yeah now I
want to like help as many people as
possible and get things to happen in a
timely manner itself I see lots of
lawyers who their clients are a source
of revenue for them you know that's that
happens every day and in every field not
just criminal law sure but I also see a
lot of lawyers who are very passionate
and advocates for their clients who do a
lot of things for their clients that
they're not getting paid for and you
know those those lawyers I admire
because you know it's not easy to
represent criminal defendants in the
American criminal justice system yeah so
when did you get into teaching when did
you decide to make that move well first
I went to law school and then after that
I decided that my first job I'd like to
clerk for a federal judge and had a lot
of people tell me
that may not be able to happen for you
Sean you've done well in law school but
there may be some people that will not
think that you should be clerking and I
also got some advice from people when I
was in law school about if you do apply
for a federal clerkship only apply to
Democrat appointees Republican
appointees will not give you the time of
day given your background interesting
and yet almost every judge that
interviewed me or was interested in me
was a Republican appointee and and
ultimately it was judge Janice Rogers
Brown who was one of the most
conservative judges on the DC Circuit
she's no longer a judge now it was her
that hired me former bank robber to come
be her clerk at the second most
important court in the country yeah
so I want to obviously get into your
time there but what do you make of that
that statement that you just said that
people said well it'll probably be a
Democrat but it turned out to be a
Republican well I think I think people
don't realize that I think of for a lot
of conservatives they really redemption
stories resonate with them mm-hmm
whether it's the faith aspect or just
you know they probably view me as a pick
yourself up by the bootstraps story
which that's not entirely accurate
because if I don't have people I accept
lacks one of my wife none of this
happens but I think that resonated with
them and and they you know I had lots of
judges who wanted to give me an
opportunity yeah
and now basically you are helping a lot
of young people get that opportunity
yeah yes Paul Chambers of federal judges
all the time to try and get my students
clerkships
yeah and so you know I spent a year
clerking and I got to see kind of how
the sausage is made a pellet court and
what was the most mind-blowing part of
that were there things that you saw that
you were like wow this is really messed
up and it this will probably lead us to
a lot of the issues that you're fighting
about all the time well I was surprised
sometimes at the level of advocacy even
on a court in Washington DC that's
viewed as the second most important
court in the country a lot of times the
advocacy was really bad especially in
criminal cases
you mean the public defenders
public defenders may even privately
retain lawyers at least public defenders
care mmm-hmm and so they won't just
check it in but I saw privately retain
lawyers that would file things that were
incomprehensible
I also saw government agencies that did
that so you know I mean at the DC
Circuit you got a lot of administrative
law decisions I felt like I needed an
acronym charge the EPA and NLRB and and
the dreaded the worst was FERC no one
wanted FERC cases should I even ask
Federal Energy Regulatory Commission
anytime someone wants to build a
pipeline FERC is involved anytime
someone wants to do nuclear energy or
electric energy FERC is involved and
they're constantly being sued so and
they're not the most exciting cases in
the world right so to that point though
how much did you see you're talking
about the sausage being made how much
did you see have just sort of like a
corroded system like just a lot of
nonsense that that didn't need to be
there you know just like a lot of brush
in the way well I think the law is way
too complex but I was was astounded at
the judges on the DC Circuit these are
incredibly smart people who really care
and I was impressed by all of them just
their dedication to the work and trying
to find right answers and so many of how
we think about courts as politically
based on divided decisions between
conservatives and liberals but for most
of those cases we had at the DC Circuit
that it was not a political issue and so
it was an issue that basically all the
judges were trying to just find the
right answer
yeah after being around this after being
in prison and part of that system and
then you know working with judges and
now and now teaching and all that how
much you think politics sort of seeped
into all of this do you think people are
judges I'm talking about lawyers
everybody do you think public defenders
do you think people are able to remove
their own political biases no of course
not of course not
III see politics plays a big role in
everything even the courts and I don't
think anyone would disagree with that
what I would say is that again there's a
large number of cases that don't involve
that that are pretty straightforward and
that is the bulk of federal courts
docket it's just we tend to focus on the
big case especially at the Supreme Court
the five before decisions sure and we
don't realize that there are a whole lot
of unanimous decisions and a lot of
collegiality on the court except for in
the big political cases yeah so there
are a couple issues that are sort of
your pet issues now that are very
personal to you obviously so mandatory
minimums you are you are not a fan to
say lawful just describe what they are
first but yeah so mandatory minimums are
aware Congress sets a particular
mandatory floor for the judge has to
impose that sentence and I'll give you
example of one of the worst ones there
is a statute that says if you use a
firearm during a crime of violence or a
drug trafficking crime you get five
years consecutive to whatever else you
get whether it's bank robbery drug crime
and then every second time consecutive
so this is happening at the same time no
matter what so so if you get three years
for the robberies and just five years
for the gun you're gonna do eight years
yeah the second time you know that seems
not consecutive I would have thought
they're sort of built on top of each
other like you know you say okay the
other yeah and then you'd get a target
with a second use of the firearm it's 25
years mm-hmm
had that played out for me and had I
gone to trial I would have had five bank
robberies and these five gun charges i
pled guilty to the five bank robberies
and one gun charge my sentence was
twelve years three months if I had gone
to trial and been convicted of the five
gun charges I would have received a
sentence of ninety two years and three
months the judge would have had to
impose it there was a very well known
case of Weldon Angelo's a man in Utah
who had a young family with selling
marijuana to support his young kids and
made three small sales of marijuana
while having a gun and he ends up
getting sentenced to 55 years he's now
been released I know other people I've
got a good friend
who's named Adam Clausen who did nine
robberies went to trial and the only
difference between his case in my case
is I had a good lawyer he didn't I had a
reasonable prosecutor he didn't I pled
guilty he exercised his right to a jury
trial and as a result he got a sentence
of 213 years in federal prison
Wow even though no one was physically
hurt in the robberies so it makes no
sense to me yeah so far as misguided as
obviously you would argue these laws are
the art the counter-argument would be
that this is going to deter people I
think that's what the counter-argument
is but as you said before nobody
understands this stuff so have they done
Studies on that like oh yeah this is a
literature all says that the thing that
deters people is whether or not they're
gonna get caught not the length of the
sentence no one thinking about the
punishment when they're committing
crimes and so you're getting very little
deterrent effect yeah and so then the
question is well why do we impose
mandatory minimums and the government
would say well we need mandatory
minimums to get people to plead guilty
well we have a problem in the federal
system with too many people plead guilty
ninety seven percent mm-hmm and that
shouldn't be our primary focus and yes I
see why is that so high ninety-seven
percent because the punishments are so
high if you are offered three years and
you might be in a center have a triable
case and you're offered a plea deal of
three years but if you go to trial
you're gonna get 20 what would you do
even if you're innocent what would you
do yeah you'd probably take two three
years because the consequences are so
severe so these all of these people that
got these ridiculously high punishments
at first when I started seeing them I
thought maybe there is a connection to
race or socioeconomic class but really
what I see are people that exercise
their constitutional right to a jury
trial mm-hmm get thrown in prison for
the rest of their lives simply because
they did that and you know the jury
trial right was it's the only right
that's both contained in the body of the
Constitution and in the bill of rights
yeah I understand important thing
yeah so basically these laws the system
is sort of forcing you to not use your
constitutional rights I mean that's
really fascinating that's atherton what
they call a trial penalty if you go to
trial you will get crushed because the
Department of Justice has 5000 federal
statutes many of them contain mandatory
minimum punishments think about that
five thousand things that you could
potentially do that would warrant
putting you in prison or jail I'd argue
that the United States Congress does not
know you your Liberty if there are five
thousand things that they think are so
serious that you could go to prison for
yeah I think you're gonna say there's
five thousand things the United States
Congress could be in jail for yeah I
mean I think most people break federal
law all the time and don't know it
like what for example people that omit
something material when they're selling
something on Craigslist or Ebay that's
wire fraud and I can tell you the last
three presidents the United States
committed a federal felony all three
there's a statute that says if you use
or abuse drugs any drug listen under the
controlled substance act and then
possess a firearm you are it's like
you're felon in possession of a firearm
hmm President Clinton what'd he say I
didn't I smoked but I didn't inhale
President Bush admitted to using drugs
and so did President Obama and all three
of them have possessed firearms since
then mm-hmm they could have been
convicted and sentence up to 10 years in
federal prison so we have a Congress
that has passed 5,000 things and right
these really broad statutes and when
they do that what they pass is no longer
the law because what is the law is
whatever your local United States
Assistant Attorney decides to prosecute
that's the law not what Congress passes
because Congress has criminalized
everything but really decided nothing
okay so the whole prison and law
conversation often is framed around
drugs so we talked about this briefly
right before we started but we both have
some frustrations with our current
Attorney General so basically a few
years ago Obama's assistant attorney
general passed this memo or instigated
this memo that said that the feds
weren't going to go after States
for legalizing marijuana is that yeah
broadly correct okay now it appears that
sessions is getting rid of that memo so
it's a little unclear does that mean
they're gonna start doing it or did he
just not like the memo or what is a
small government guy want the states to
be able to do whatever they want do you
have any insight into what's actually
going on here yeah and and and I'm not
certain that I disagree with the
Attorney General on the memo federal law
says this is illegal it's really strange
for DOJ to then come in with a memo that
says we're not going to enforce federal
law but what the memo does is just
leaves it to the discretion of local US
Attorney's and I would be surprised if
any of them decided that they wanted to
go after people for marijuana in states
where it's legalized but what really
needs to happen like the real solution
to this is not a memo from DOJ it's the
Congress saying we're not gonna be in
this business anymore let's let States
decide this you would think in a
Republican Congress that claims to be
for states rights that they would do
that I mean the West Coast has spoken
Alaska Washington Oregon California
Nevada Colorado I mean there there is a
movement here of states that have said
we as a policy matter think locking up
people for marijuana is not helping the
problem so what does this tell you about
the way the federal government works
because you're right a Republican
administration or Republican Congress
everything else by by logic if logic has
anything to do with politics which I
know it often doesn't they should not be
going after states I mean it's
completely the reverse of what they say
they are for now we don't know he's
gonna do it that's what you're saying
there may have just been something in
the memo that he didn't like but it just
it just this is one of the reasons that
people just hate politics I think yeah
it's because it's so hard to get
movement on these issues and and part of
it is the politics of crime no one runs
on I'm gonna be smart about criminal
justice issues as always we got to be
tough we got to be tough we got to be
tough but you know you look and we have
spent trillions of dollars on the war on
drugs we've locked up hundreds of
thousands of our city
Suns and drug usage rates are pretty
steady over an entire 30-year period and
it turns out you just can't get around
addiction issues by locking people up
and the opah opioid crisis is a good
example of that posing mandatory minimum
sentences on people who are in the
throes of addiction is not going to work
because you could tell someone who's
addicted to heroin if you keep doing it
I'm gonna put you in prison for twenty
years and I'm not certain it would
matter yeah what they need is treatment
not present so what happens to that
conversation where our cuz you don't
hear I mean I guess you hear it a little
bit maybe but where are the politicians
or the public figures saying guys
instead of funding all of this money to
the prisons you know keeping these
people here forever all right many of
them going back right the day after they
get out all of this stuff where are the
people saying we have to help them break
addiction yeah I mean the problem one of
the problems I see is we focused on
back-end solutions and so the Federal
Bureau of Prisons is a third of do J's
budget if we stopped locking up so many
people and spent some of that money on
treatment or spent the money on more
federal law enforcement who actually
solved more crimes that might actually
deter people mm-hmm but just punishing
people through bit long sentences is
never gonna have that deterrent effect
that the government wants and and you
know you you also can't say that we are
the land of liberty on the one hand and
then on the other recognize that we
incarcerate our citizens at a greater
rate than almost any other country on
the planet
yeah 2.2 million people in prisons are
jail in America today that's Houston
yeah as you say that that's more than
some small countries yeah that is
Houston locked up all around the country
and and for a country that claims to be
the land of the free those two things
are just incompatible and inconsistent
with each other yeah so I understand the
federal level and why there's so much
sort of gridlock with that are there any
states that are doing this really much
better than other states yeah Texas
recently closed a bunch of prisons and
decided that they were going to try and
rehabilitate more people and as they
close prisons and release more prisoners
you know what happened to their crime
rate it went down well turns out there's
not a great correlation between crime
rate and incarceration rate people
commit crimes for all sorts of reasons
the economy how the economy is doing is
probably the biggest factor mm-hmm
but just locking people up is not going
to solve the problem of crime and you
know we have fairly historic low rates
of crime at the moment but you would
never know that by our Corrections
practices and by the number of people we
prosecute and put into prisons and jails
every day yeah what are some of your
other pet peeve issues I know the
mandatory minimum one I know is the big
president reform is another one it's
just my belief that if we are gonna let
someone out of prison someday why would
we not want to spend a little bit of
money for rehabilitation and job
training you spend a little bit of money
so that you save a whole lot of money by
not them getting out of prison and not
committing new crimes not being
reprosecution car serrated say spend a
little money to save a lot of money to
me that's good government is there
virtually no job training in federal
prison so you were sort of self-training
and I'm sure there are other people that
learn shop or learn some other trades
but is there really nothing well I mean
that they have not allocated a great
deal of money towards that and then the
wardens of federal prisons have a lot of
discretion I'll give you one example
president I was at we had a really great
welding program men we're learning this
trade they were getting out they were
getting jobs paying twenty five dollars
an hour which that's the gold standards
great people getting out people don't
care if you have a felony if you can
weld and do the job twenty five bucks an
hour if you get out of college that is
pretty decent and and what a warden came
allens thought well I can get more money
if I change the program so he changed
the welding program and put in an
associate's degree program in business
management because we know that every
person wants to hire a former person
from the prison to help manage and run
their business these are the decisions I
saw all the time
the system and and most of them just
don't make any sense what we need to do
is open those prisons up get more
volunteers get businesses into the
prisons provide job training and basic
life skills somebody the men I served
time with had never had a bank account
and it's the little things when I got
out of prison I got to the halfway house
I was told you need to get a job before
we'll give you a pass to leave and you
can't get a job until you get a bank
account and I went to the bank and they
said you haven't banked for 11 years
what's the deal I had to tell them why
and then I find out that the credit
agencies had listed me as deceased
Jesus and so I go back to the halfway
house and I'm like I can't even get the
process started getting a job because I
can't get a bank account and I said well
you need to hire a lawyer to get this
for ya I just did a letter to Joe yeah I
need a lawyer that I can't afford to get
the bank account to get the job to get
the money yeah that doesn't compute and
for a lot of people when they hit those
roadblocks they don't know how to cope
with them and what they do is they
revert back to the things they do now
yeah I mean I mentioned Shawshank before
but it's like it reminds me of both you
know there was red and the old guy with
the bird I'm blanking who was that
blanking on his name yeah but you know
Red's patsies a gun in the in the window
and he's thinking maybe I should get
back in there and the old guy like ends
up killing himself because they can't
function they just can't even alized
institutional when you are taken from a
system where everything is controlled
and you're in a system that says you are
a piece of garbage everyone in there
that is the message you get every day in
prison that you are a piece of garbage
where you're here to suffer punishment
and you're not gonna get out and lead a
successful life that has an impact on
people you know I got out and wasn't
aware of what I could do I had but I had
a woman who was intelligent and
beautiful and who loved me who said you
can go to law school and I had a former
Solicitor General the United States
telling me I could go to law school that
had a profound
packed on me and my own self-worth and
whether I thought I could do some of
these things had I not had that I don't
think I would have even tried to go to
law school yeah so on that note let's
let's talk about some of the good stuff
so you're teaching law now what are kids
excited by it right now like what do you
see them caring about criminal justice
reform is a big topic it's big
everywhere I go I see more people
writing about it people talking about it
Pew just put out a study yesterday
saying an overwhelming number of
Americans support criminal justice
reform and I think people get it like we
are sending people to prison to many
people to prison for too long we use
incarceration as a first response rather
than a last resort and it doesn't work
the irony is the longer you send someone
to prison the less likely they are to
come out and be law-abiding successful
citizens and so why are we doing it yeah
tell me a bit a little bit about about
teaching in general I mean it must be
pretty frickin rewarding for you to be
doing it is and it's fun when I'm
teaching fourth amendment to students or
fifth amendment Miranda issues yeah and
now I'm teaching a Prison Law and Policy
class where we are diving into both
legal doctrine about what are the
constitutional rights that prisoners
retain why they're incarcerated and
getting into the policy aspects of why
do we impose solitary confinement on
people we know that it makes people who
have mental illness it exacerbates their
mental illness and we know that people
without mental illness that causes it
mm-hmm
so why would you want to impose long
terms of solitary confinement on people
that are eventually going to be released
from prison why are we putting sex
offenders in prison and not trying to
rehabilitate them before we kick them to
the outside world and before the
neighbors for me and my young kids
anyone that has an out date we should be
trying to reform and rehabilitate and I
think with a little bit of resources and
opening presents up to more volunteers
we can make a big impact on the
recidivism rate so you would basically
want so it sounds like you basically
want to sort of less laws in
general perhaps even less funding or at
least you'd want to shift the funding to
some other things and then you think
you've involuntary and things like that
could actually help than I do I think
people would come in and teach courses
I've seen it in prisons I went to a
private prison in Texas in December and
this prison had allowed a company to
come in and build an assembly line and
this woman I spoke to at this woman's
prison said I'm making $9 an hour in
prison now she said the state takes $3
of that an hour but I make enough money
where I can send six or seven hundred
dollars to my daughter who is a Baylor
University for her rent she said I can't
tell you how great it feels to
contribute to my daughter's life and be
able to do it from here
and she said I'm gonna be able to take
these skills that I'm learning and go
get a job with this company or a similar
company when I get out of prison why
would we not want to do more of that
yeah I think it's kind of amazing that
twice now you've used Texas as an
example of a state that's doing this
right I think if you would have asked me
before we sat down what state probably
has the most backwards legal laws and
Prison laws I probably would have said
Texas which is probably just the
terrible stereotype but that's really
interesting
well Texas has at issues too I mean
there's no state that's doing it well
but there are states that are ramping
down punishments and realizing that if
we do put people in prison we need to
incentivize them people that are in
prison respond to incentives just like
anyone else California recently passed a
bill that incentivizes prisoners by
cutting their sentence short if they
take rehabilitation programing and
that's something that that we my company
prison professors are talking with
Correctional Association's all over the
country about this is what you should be
doing you incentivize excellence when I
was in prison all of the things I did
the legal briefs I won two Supreme Court
cases court cases all over the country
it was clear to people in the prison
that I was on a different trajectory
than a lot of people and that I was not
going to be a safety risk when I got out
and yet no matter what I did it didn't
sortin my sentence
one day hmm and I tell you that you know
the first five years in prison I deserve
to be there but I grew up and I found
the law and got responsibility and the
last five years I wasn't a danger to
anyone else I had grown up and I was
just warehoused yeah so I know you focus
obviously mostly on criminal law it's
the most personal thing to you and it's
what you're teaching and everything else
what are the other parts of the law laws
that were not paying a tendon of
attention to for example you just
mentioned the Fourth Amendment right to
privacy I feel like people don't even
understand that we have a right to
privacy yeah yeah I mean the Fourth
Amendment is a really tough area of law
because there aren't any hard and fast
rules and because of the exclusionary
rule courts are very reticent to say
there's a Fourth Amendment violation
because the consequence is all of the
evidence is thrown out and the person
may go yeah maybe the cases gets
dismissed right there's an interesting
catch-22 yeah and so you know what you
see is courts I mean the Supreme Court
slowly starting to get more concerned
about technology and privacy there's a
big case pending up there about whether
your cell phone metadata requires a
warrant for the government to go get a
warrant before they can look at that
data and you know with GPS technology
these days they can get your data from
your cell phone and tell exactly what
you've been doing where you've gone if
you visit a doctor they'll know you may
have an illness if they see you've done
it several times so in effect has the
ship sailed on that then I mean how do
we have a right to privacy we don't in
the digital age yeah it's really
difficult this is one of the reasons why
it's so hard for people coming out of
prison because there are so many
collateral consequences be discriminated
against and housing employment you can
lose your voting rights and you can't
really hide it anymore so we have all
these initiatives to ban the Box ban the
question on the application mm-hmm but
if employers can just run a Google
search and find out that you committed a
felony I'm not certain that just pushing
that information to the interview is
going to lead to more people getting
jobs right and so I would like to see
more groups just go to employers go to
big companies and
say affirmative Lehi er people coming
out of prison try it maybe give them a
tax break or some sort of incentive to
get them to employ these people because
there are a whole lot of people coming
out we want the primary reason why they
go back to committing crimes is they
can't find employment in a place to live
yeah you mentioned to me briefly in the
green room that you're trying to work on
some stuff with the white house right
now yeah so I sat at the table a couple
weeks ago as the president said that we
need prison reform and they're trying to
push a bill in the House is going to
start in the house that would provide
incentives to prisoners to take
rehabilitation programs so that we can
reduce the recidivism rate and I'm a big
believer that that we can if we
structure things in the appropriate
manner yeah so on this case this sounds
like something good that Trump's trying
to push through which usually isn't
prison reform usually thought of as a
lefty or a progressive idea it is but
there are more and more conservative
groups who understand that the criminal
justice system has gotten too big and
compasses too much law too many things
are criminalized and we are over relying
on incarceration and it's funny I go
around to every single group in DC the
Heritage Foundation Cato the Koch
Institute ACLU and double ACP these
people can agree on nothing but they all
agree that the criminal justice system
as a massaman to be fixed yeah
what do you see is there giant
differences though in the solution so I
would imagine some of the ones on the
right you just mentioned they just want
the government to do less or get rid of
some regulation laws
ones on the left want the government
probably to do more yeah I mean I think
everyone realizes we need to reevaluate
sentences and the lengths of sentences I
think there's disagreement with various
how various crimes are prosecuted like
environmental crimes Congress likes to
pass statutes without what they call
mens rea ax requirements that you
knowingly violated the law and people on
the Left would say it's really hard to
get CEOs and companies that do this to
be prosecuted if you have the mens rea
oh we're
on the right they're a big believer that
men's Raya is a necessary part if we're
gonna send you to prison you shouldn't
it's because you knowingly violated the
law mm-hmm yeah that's or knowingly
committed an act of violated the law
right but as you were saying before
there are so many laws at this point
that really nobody knows nobody knows
yeah you have 5,000 statutes over 5,000
no one has an accurate count the carry
criminal penalties now administrative
agencies can sometimes create
regulations with criminal penalties and
you have a californian you probably have
another two or three thousand statutes
so there are eight nine ten thousand
things that you can do wrong that may
lead to you going to jail or prison I
would say that state legislatures and
the Congress does not value individual
liberty if that's the case we went for
the majority of this country's founding
we went and used civil penalties fines
money damages to solve a lot of these
problems and somewhere along the way in
the 70s and 80s we thought we needed to
fix everything with prison sentences
yeah I mean it's just it's it's so
backwards you know it I mean like I
think a lot of my audience watching this
is going
I like intuitively you just know this
that there's something so just wrong
with this system and yet it just keeps
trucking along so maybe you look if
trump's passing something that that
you're involved in and it gets to the
house maybe something a little moving
yeah I'm greatly encouraged by the White
House's passion for this issue Jared
Kushner is incredibly passionate about
it his dad went to federal prison in
2002 he's been directly impacted most
people I know don't understand the
criminal justice system till a family
member gets caught up and then they
realize oh my gosh this is a mess yeah
and a huge problem and you know I think
I think conservatives in the house and
in the Senate will get on board with
prison reform and my hope is that it
will be a piece of bipartisan
legislation because this is one of the
few bipartisan issues that we have in
the country yeah I'm curious do you ever
coach and
any inmates now you ever go to a prison
and find somebody and be like you know
let me tell you my story I have a lot of
people I stay in contact with presence I
go into prisons and give talks all the
time my recent thing has been mentoring
people that have committed serious
felonies who are now on their way to
currently in or recently graduated from
law school and a lot of them are now
getting law licenses this summer well
and it's been interesting to see because
I probably had several hundred lawyers
tell me you never go to law school even
if you do graduate from law school no
State Bar Association is ever gonna let
you become an attorney and they were
just wrong
yeah and so I got to argue a case for
one of my friends in the Washington
State Supreme Court this past fall it
was the first time the court had taken
what they call a character and fitness
case whether you have the character and
fitness necessary to practice law first
time they had taken a case in 37-years
argued the case on the way home on the
plane I get a text saying that the court
ruled unanimously two hours after the
oral argument in favor of my client
well she's now gonna take the bar exam
in February and she'll probably be a
lawyer by May so the counter-argument
was simply that she had been in jail
basically so she benefic it had drug
addiction issues although she'd been
clean for six years and she had had
extraordinary success in law school
graduated with honors had won all of
these awards had been appointed to
commissions by the governor of
Washington and supported by a huge
amount of licensed attorneys and the bar
still tonight or six today so then we
have to waste all this time and money
and energy and resources to allow her to
go ahead and yeah what do we do to get
rid of all of that so cuz a lot of what
you're talking about is just generally I
think what people are frustrated by with
government just like this mid-level
bloat nobody really knows what's going
on there are either resilient laws or
resilient regulations that half of them
conflict with each other just all of
that what do you really do to remove I
don't know like the occupational
licensing scheme
are really impactful for people coming
out of prison because many of them say
if you have a felony we're just not
letting you do these professions right
and you know so I don't want to clean
the pool or something a new laser I
don't I don't think that we need people
coming out who have committed sex
offenses teaching and junior high
schools I get that sometimes there are
offenses that apply to a particular job
but most of these things aren't looking
at the crime the person committed it's
just across the board policy of you're
not going to be allowed in the
profession and when you lock people
coming out of prison from all of these
professions you make it very difficult
for them to ever get back to having a
real life yeah well your story is
obviously inspiring so this is I've
really enjoyed this did we did we miss
anything major on the legal front that
we should absolutely knock out like I
feel like we hit your you know yeah good
you know we did our whole Star Wars talk
already on the green whoops I think
we're good
well it's a pleasure chatting with you
and for more on Sean you can follow him
on Twitter it's Sean Hopwood that's sth
o n h o p wo OD
[Music]
you
[Music]